The writer HG Wells, who
first imagined time machines
and alien invasions, had a
nightmare of a future world
where atoms were weaponized.
In his book called "The World
Set Free", written in 1913,
he coined the
phrase atomic bombs
and loosed them on helpless
civilian populations.
He set his vision of a nuclear
war between England and Germany
in the impossibly distant
future of the 1950s.
[music playing]
[bomb exploding]
In 1933, the Hungarian
physicist, Leo Szilard,
was contemplating
becoming a biologist.
Dr. Szilard?
Are you quite all
right in there?
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
He read Wells's novel,
and it started him thinking.
Szilard knew that atoms are
made of protons and neutrons
on the inside and
a skittering vale
of electrons on the outside.
Suddenly, while
waiting for the light
to change at this
intersection in London,
he was struck by the thought,
if he could find a sufficiently
large amount of an element
that would emit two neutrons
when it absorbed
one, it would sustain
a nuclear chain reaction.
Two would produce four, four
would produce eight, and so
forth, until enormous amounts
of energy in the nucleus
itself could be liberated.
Not a chemical reaction,
but a nuclear one.
[alarm wailing]
[bomb exploding]
[music playing]
This was the moment
our world changed.
Leo Szilard also knew the
power of exponentials,
and if a neutron chain reaction
could be triggered down there
in the world of
the atom's nucleus,
then something like Wells's
imaginary atomic bomb
might be possible.
He shuddered at the thought of
this destructive capability.
It was just the
latest development
on a continuum of violence
that began long, long before.
50,000 years ago, all
humans were roving
bands of hunter-gatherers.
They communicated
over limited areas
by calling to one another,
that is, at the speed of sound,
around 750 miles per hour,
but over longer distances,
they could communicate only
as fast as they could run.
Around 12,000 years ago, about
the same time as the invention
of agriculture, they
developed the power
to kill at a longer distance.
The kill radius expanded
to the arc of an arrow
launched by a bow,
and they could kill
one person with a single arrow.
Our ancestors were not
particularly warlike
because there were so few
people and so much room
back then that moving on was
preferable to armed conflict.
Their weapons were used
almost entirely for hunting.
Their identification
horizon was likely small,
only with the other members of
their band of 50 or 100 people.
But their time horizon
took a giant leap.
They worked long and
hard planting crops
in the here and now,
so several months
later, they could harvest them.
They postponed
present gratification
for later advantage.
They began to plan
for the future.